yo
so a lot of this was face replacements
that's not something that like you just
simulate you don't just hit a button and
it gets made
there is way more cg in here than you
would actually expect wait those are 3d
animations yeah yeah
oh my god
hey welcome back to another episode of
visual effects artist react today we are
joined by sean walker from whatafx he's
in town for this little thing you might
know called the academy awards
sean what exactly do you do at weta so i
am the visual effects supervisor which
means that i am essentially financially
and creatively responsible for all the
the stuff that we usually respond in
case anything fails exactly
my team and myself are responsible for
creating the final delivered shots to
the studio in this case changchi and the
legend of the ten rings basically we
have a creative a lot of the times we
are delivered artwork from marvel and
that's the end goal to try and reach the
point where we can line up to the
creative that works for them and then
once we you know design the look for all
the shots we have to figure out how to
actually do all those shots so for
example chiang chi we had an enormous
amount of water work to do water work is
incredibly tricky what's so hard about
water
why can't you just like you know
hit the button yeah
exactly what it does it's just an
incredibly render intensive effect to
work and to get to look right the render
time it takes to actually produce these
renders for water is very intense the
water effects from shangshi were like
specifically mentioned in the episode
with joe pharrell in the comments
because everyone's like i can't believe
you didn't talk about the water i was
like oh just you wait
[Music]
yo that's cool is that just one
simulation there or are you dealing with
like four or five different like
elements that artists have put together
to make it happen so there are actually
four or five elements in here as well
yeah this is a bit of a blend and i tell
you this one was
very very art directed there was a lot
of problems with it in the first place
to make sure that a character hits the
water still continues along the length
of the water surface so water
interaction is one thing the
other thing is actually having the water
move like a character we've never done
that before and that's where it started
to get pretty interesting we had brian
grills on the show he was talking about
how you're trying to strike this really
tricky balance between physics and what
water actually does and then like what
the director wants yeah what you need to
do creatively to tell your story and
very often one breaks the other i mean
ideally and realistically he would just
go into the water and you wouldn't see
him again but we really wanted to see
him go into the distance without parting
the water so much that it felt too anime
did the director just say i don't want
it to feel too animated
we actually did take a lot of
inspiration from anime the very first
thing i did when we saw the previous
come through of chiang chi running up
the side of the dragon was look at
attack on titan oh yeah and yeah see the
the characters running along the length
of the arms oh no yeah it's pretty
classic
i really wanted to
film the underwater shots a little bit
more accurately than i think has been
done before if you ever look at
underwater photography a lot of specular
highlights on the skin and the eyes it's
minimized pretty much nothing and i
thought we could achieve that by using
polarized light so we did a bunch of
tests and we did all these grades and
underwater atmospherics and it looked
pretty good and chris townsend marvel's
vfx supervisor took that setup and i
think he tried to implement that as much
as possible here but it wasn't quite the
setup there's a fine balance between you
know getting the lighting that you want
and actually
making something realistic as well so
here we looked for a more beautiful sort
of lighting scenario and then just
graded the highlights out here so why
not just film underwater
simu's not a good swimmer
i'm not sure
there are definitely certain films that
will go that way for sure it's just
preference and cost i think as well and
just being able to go ahead and set
something like that up but it's much
easier of course to film something in
the studio than it is underwater true
and i suppose if you have a whole
pipeline built it's like we're going to
be putting the cg dragon in the
true you shot anyway
color green and blue and you know defuse
a little bit like yeah i guess he could
do that
[Laughter]
he breached the gate those things are
going to kill us all if we don't work
together
this shot here oh my god so all of these
shots there is way more cg in here than
you would actually expect go back and
just pause on one of those shots and
let's just guess yeah i was yeah exactly
these days literally all of it could be
except for like the main actors here so
like maybe the ninjas in the background
the building in the background the
background
you're pretty much right there's just a
small bit of grass in the foreground
with a bush but everything beyond the
white banister there is cg the big
problem was that they they filmed all of
this in sunny sydney australia
everything was being hit by hard
sunlight so any play that came in that
had hard sunlight hitting uh had to be
replaced really all the characters or
the background extras were all getting
hit by hard sunlight so we match moved
every single one of them wait those are
3d animations yeah yeah
oh my god
so this is where it got a little bit
wild because
they had a crane that suspended this
insanely large sheet basically it was
there to shadow everything in the
foreground and so you had this hard
shadow line on the ground everywhere and
everything beyond that hard shadow line
we had to pretty much replace at a
certain point i guess what i'm confused
about is like why not shoot this in a
studio then and then eventually get to
just
really controlled studio lighting
towards the end of the sequence this set
was ginormous it was pretty much the
entire village so they wanted to make
sure that they could actually film the
whole thing as much as possible
these shots were extraordinarily
complicated when they came in and it
gave our animators a little bit of a
heart attack
when you see like 50 people in the
background just blindly swinging at
something you don't know what it is but
there's something here something
you always think okay we've got to put
something in there we've got to animate
these multi-tentacled winged crazy
creatures for every one of these swings
we did just hear that tentacles are the
hardest thing to animate they are
particularly yes
so all your animators are just like oh
my god we have a literally an army
fighting an invisible army and now we
have to invent the invisible army
exactly so did the animators have to
like go in and like make everything
perfectly match or they just kind of be
like ah this little flutter around and
the noise as well there's a little bit
of that so unless they were 100
interacting with the characters we had
enough variation animation to have a
match for each of these onset stunt
devils
[Music]
so a lot of this was face replacements
simu and tony did a ton of their own
work but all of this was stunt people
for face replacements they just like i
could just see me just like
make this motion that roughly matches
the other one will cut it out or you
like full on 3d scanning and like uh
yeah so we had full-on digital doubles
for both of these we approached the face
replacements in a multitude of ways the
stunt doubles here didn't always have
the same head shape so we did try and go
the route of just projecting the faces
on but in the end it ended up being a
mix of digital head replacements
projected faces and a little bit of
machine learning as well oh really yeah
when you see machine learning you mean
deep fakes yes exactly yeah you guys are
trying to favorite with that a little
bit yep we had it pipelined pretty well
by the end of it but uh it wasn't quite
there yet so instead of doing stunty to
uh to acta we did digital double the
actor what it did do is help us get a
little bit closer to i think the
character of or the actor as far as the
way they smile and the way they perform
that's cool we've actually we've seen a
ton of this online like any time or the
past like four years when a movie comes
out with like a cg actor or a knack
that's passed away invariably somebody
goes here i put a deep fake on it now it
looks a little bit better
yeah and it makes sense because you know
it's like ilm or whatever somebody goes
through the effort like full on cg face
replacement it's like okay great and
somebody else because it's like yeah
i'll just i'll just have the deep fake
like and just like fix the little tiny
things that like aren't quite 100 dialed
in by cg and it does usually look a
little bit better so it's actually
really cool to hear you guys saying that
you know you're starting to experiment
with that that passage like to find a
little bit of like spice on your shot
because you know you have to go through
the effort of changing the face shape
and dealing with the hair and the collar
interaction like that's all part of it
that a deep fake can't do but then you
can just like and just apply a little
bit of things
like this is pretty good but you know
what a little bit
[Laughter]
this whole set was entirely digital they
started to film on a what we call like a
fragmented set so they had just a little
partial piece at the bottom of the gate
and all the ground the ground kind of
looked rubbery it didn't match up to our
digital representation anyway and you
could tell because at a certain point in
time we started getting delivered plates
that had they just said yet screw it
let's uh this isn't gonna work and they
just started blue screening off all the
set that they had already made wow yeah
i remember seeing on end game where
after the whole compound had been
cratered it was all shot and like this
sort of like burnt out foresty type
thing and then it was all replaced
exactly yeah no our initial roof for
that was it was the avengers compound uh
boarded basically like a forest and at
some point they were like no let's just
make it more industrial and so almost
all of the environment there was
completely cg as well we had to roto all
of the characters and replace everything
i've had to do that more times than i
can possibly imagine like uh on a
guidance of the galaxy as well like it's
just a it's just a bit of a theme it
seems like big movies take for granted
these days that people are just going to
cut out and roto everything yeah
that's exactly right yeah again i think
we're there to support the story and if
the story requires things to be a little
bit different than that's the possible
take
coming soon corridor crew one lone
artist takes on corridor's greatest
champion in vfx our own artist
competitors have two hours to present a
cgi dish to the mythical vfx react crew
kenny hero top villain empire tune in
this wednesday to find out i'll catch it
a day early on corridordigital.com
[Applause]
this whole water spike thing coming up
and curling around the the final demon
here you know it has a very solid feel
to it it almost kind of looks like ice
and yet i see a bunch of waves and foam
rippling across its surface yeah that's
not something that like you just like
simulate you don't just hit a button
this is the first time i think we've
really done water where it had to be
artistically directed in this way we
never really had it move like a
character and that's kind of how we
actually approached it so our animation
team actually animated all these
tendrils in the first place we had a
incredibly talented artist sarah yu she
would generate all the water surface and
the tendrils we call these things sarah
spirals
in the end and because there was so much
water work here we actually had a water
team that did very individual unique
things for each simulation in each shot
so we had someone doing the water
surface we would have someone who would
do the additional rippling on top we had
someone who would do the white water
foam someone who is specifically just
doing the spin drift you know the the
white water spray that comes off the top
so
very specific but it was kind of the way
we needed to approach it to actually get
all these water shots done
this shot here the water alone took
something like 25 million threaded
render hours i think to to produce which
i think takes your average sort of
high-end computer maybe about
25 years to render
damn and it's just this one shot that's
at least four or five thirty ninety
yeah there was a few sweaty people when
this shot hit the render wall because
even a render wall of our size we took
up a good 60 of it for quite a few days
the people in avatar were like
i like the idea you guys still have to
deal with resources just like
sorry guys our computers are busy it's
like the fact that weta is still so much
like you guys are stressing your
computer to the point where it's like
we're all out of memory yes
it's like a goldfish in a goldfish bowl
right yeah you're always going to use up
every resource that you have
gigi double cg double no
it was him running around on a natural
beast i think
[Laughter]
no i uh so this one was one of those
sort of big shots it was much much
longer a lot of marvel films have what
they call the wanna and it's just like
this big action beat lots of things
happening the thing that we tried to do
a lot of the time here even if you're
running around on a dragon you know it
can't possibly be real you always want
to make sure that the cameraman is in a
reasonable position that it's being
filmed in a way that seems plausible so
when we run off the back of the dragon
here you know the camera remains running
and jumping off with him he's literally
following the action jumping over the
tentacles you know we have pretty much a
virtual camera guy in here making sure
that he's getting the shot he doesn't
get enough recognition
he's a very good camera person
so i was pitching this idea about what
we would see internally for the demon as
he's dying here what i wanted to happen
was all the bones and things to be
breaking off and to have all the rings
kind of swirl that on the inside
along with the rest of the guts and uh i
mean it's very quick so it's pretty hard
to see but yeah that's kind of what's
happening on the inside there
gut blending
wow and that's the result of the gut
blender exactly
you know it's been a treat as we record
these episodes getting a little bit the
inside like scoops on the story beats
it's like here's what actually happened
you can't see it but exactly
this is what happened inside it's like
yes it's our own little yeah exactly our
little sweetener so this show is behind
the scenes of visual effects in
hollywood but wouldn't you like to see
behind the scenes of how this show was
made how we go about getting our guests
we can check it out on corridor
digital.com we actually have a whole
crew cuts episode that's dropping about
that right now plus we have extended
versions of these episodes so if you
really want to nerd out about visual
effects or just get deeper into this
information or just watch these
conversations be less cut ordered.com
place to go all right it's comments time
i would like your suggestion please
suggest to me the visual effects with
the coolest destruction let's call it
the biz effects
i want to hear your coolest simulations
the coolest destruction the coolest most
mind-boggling water sims or anything
that you've seen in movies please leave
a comment down below and we will check
it out sean it's been an absolute treat
having you join us best of luck at the
oscars it's really cool that i have the
opportunity to say that to somebody
thank you so much
i really appreciate it absolutely say hi
to matt for me if you see i will that's
cool he loved being here like uh he
talks about it
great it was uh it was definitely one of
his career highlights i'm sure no way
yep absolutely
no way
[Laughter]
surely it was scanning the troll
getting control okay it's getting the
troll card occurred
oh boy
thank you
it's really cool if you just stop here
considering you you know have to go buy
your
tuxedo you know get your legs that's all
my yeah that's the visual effects like
it's just
parties and tuxedos it's totally it
totally yeah it's totally it everybody
that's exactly what it's like
that's what you should look forward to
in your visual effects career
just running around with the stars yep